[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I think there's a lot of things going on
that are driving people to experiment
and to explore and hunger for something
different it's a very interesting time
in history where people are beginning to
see the old system isn't working
not only economically ecologically but
in human terms
you can look at cooperation as an
ethical good-hearted thing or you can
look at it as something people need to
do to take your work seriously to take
other people seriously to organize
politically
this isn't touchy feeling stuff this is
about actually getting the world to work
we're in transition and what's
remarkable to me is that people feel
that in their bones we need to figure
out how to align the human economy with
the principles and patterns that tend to
operate in all living systems that's the
essence of it and so the challenge is to
kind of figure out how to switch out the
engines on the plane while we're keeping
the plane in the air
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
what if we were able to really build the
foundations of a Cooperative world
what would it look like what would be
free and exciting what would be generous
what would be moral
what would be exciting what would be
liberating
um that's the kind of direction we're
talking about
we're at Ground Zero beginning to
explore designs that take us beyond the
20th century capitalism 20th century
socialism there are a lot of people
beginning to say there's got to be a
better way
you've been talking about changing the
system the whole system
that's what this is about but that means
people have to really
start small but also think big
[Music]
housing is one of the primary social
institutions
we have an opportunity through
technology and kind of open
collaborative
philosophies that have been emerging in
the last few years to really rethink the
way that the built environment works and
the way the major societal structures
work
I
am to instigate the project that we're
sitting in right now it's called the red
Victorian and it's a 20 room hotel and
bed and breakfast that's been here for
100 years we took it over about a year
ago and turned it into what we're
calling a co-living hotel
[Music]
the red Victorian is really a new way of
thinking about home and housing in the
21st century
[Music]
It's a combination of long-term
residential accommodations but in a very
fluid way with short-term housing
options so we have people staying here
everywhere from one night to one month
to indefinitely we're aiming to serve
you know the kind of modern nomadic
creative population and so people are
often traveling or they're working late
or their schedules are very different
we don't have a particular hierarchy and
I certain when they call myself a um
like the boss or the manager or we're
all managers or you know you can think
of it in many different ways but it's a
cooperatively run space
okay which one are we looking at can I
show you something sure
the way we make decisions at the red
Victorian is open to everybody who's in
the community
I went and I met with the Department of
Public Health and they provided a couple
of options for what we could do in the
short term to be compliant uh with what
health codes are required so the first
is uh that we could be officially a bed
at breakfast and providing the breakfast
and other things that go along with that
means that only employees and innkeepers
which they don't even know what they're
defined as May provide food for the
guests but we have to provide it and the
guests can't provide it can't access it
themselves it's so silly because it like
precludes you from doing new and
Innovative stuff
we basically don't fit into any of the
boxes that they have for anything they
could basically say you've got to shut
down your hotel because you're
you're not compliant we're witnessing an
era where like the diversity of
economies are starting to flourish and
so government doesn't know what to do
but this seems to be written for like
the BNB that's family run
is what I'm saying family run bed and
breakfast that's the thing right
yeah yeah it's actually it turns out a
co-living hotel is a family-run bed and
breakfast
thanks everyone for coming tonight this
is our Wednesday dinner at the red
Victorian for those of you who may not
have been here before the red Vic is our
home
I'm really inspired by living around and
being exposed to people who are up to
amazing things in the world we can
provide an environment and a structure
that not only
selfishly gets us exposed to those
people but actually I think supports it
amplifies the work that they're doing by
making it easier for them to do what
they're doing and also to hopefully meet
others who are inspiring to them
with being totally bootstrapped up to
this point I mean I think that this
to me
and a very exciting aspect of having a
physical building is that it's an
opportunity to provide literally a
container for a whole bunch of humans to
walk through the door and when you walk
through that door we get to say hey the
rules are a little bit different here we
really like to play with that in terms
of having people getting to say actually
here you do have a say on things and
then looking at it and saying okay how's
that working like no actually that
didn't work very well but that worked
really well okay let's update how we're
doing things and try it again and sort
of a big experiment
[Music]
I first really understood about
cooperation because my background is as
a musician and of course when we play
chamber music or any kind of music that
doesn't have a conductor we have to find
ways to cooperate in other way most
musicians rehearse is by grunts
or eye contact you know or premises
like being able to really listen to the
other person uh
all three of them in fact you're kind of
trying to hear three voices in your head
at the same time as you're looking at
your own music and playing together so
you kind of get into the flow as a group
do you know what I think we need to
practice number one up just right from
there from one to two yeah why don't we
won't try one at a time why don't you do
it once with her from one
yeah we are part of one thing and you
know each each one of us have a role and
uh and sometimes we trading roles so
it's it's a real conversation sort of
uh one of the reminiscent of of life you
know so it's communicating it's fun
[Music]
foreign
we are on about one and a half acres of
Urban Land it was a parking lot
and through a partnership with Concord
Pacific we have been able to farm this
land
[Music]
so we are in urban farm
[Music]
we felt certainly a great need on the
downtown east side that nothing
agricultural was going on
that a social Enterprise based on
agriculture had the potential to not
only provide meaningful work
but also a number of other healing
aspects that occur by nature of working
the soil growing living things taking
care of something feeding other people
[Music]
so we have five Farms each is different
they each are in different neighborhoods
they each are doing different things
this is an orchard for example
Pacific and Carol our largest site big
production
and first and Clark an entire acre 16
000 square feet
of unheated tunnel houses you know we're
producing tomatoes and peppers and
melons and things like that
so we have to because of the
in the intensity and scale of the
operation we have to make maximum use of
time and space
so as soon as a crop is done boom
replant you know
here people using these words Urban
agriculture nobody had ever heard those
two words together when I would describe
it as like what
and we felt we needed to demonstrate
that it was possible to have a
successful Enterprise business based on
agriculture in the city
and at the same time support
people's needs we had to bring the farm
to the city yeah we had to create within
these boxes an entire ecosystem
kind of crazy imperfect
but has potential
[Music]
we are providing employment to people
who are facing barriers sometimes that's
an addiction sometimes that's mental
illness sometimes it's a physical
illness whatever the barrier it it makes
it hard for most of our staff to work a
regular job they need a job where
there's flexibility and understanding
about the ups and downs of their of
their lives right there lemon tree
with lemons
right that's special
it's awesome yeah yeah I I missed my
calling man should have been a [ __ ]
gardener
right you know instead of what I was
not very often like down here because
you know I get pretty rough around the
edges that you get to care and nurture
for something
when I was a kid punishment was going to
weed and garden so when I came here I
was like oh man what am I doing right I
remember this right but it's not like
that right you get into the soil and
stuff right you get to see stuff grow
and actually it's kind of beautiful
right it is beautiful it's kind of
beautiful it is beautiful
soul food has two primary goals yeah
one is a social one and I think one is
an agricultural one the social one is
first and foremost the agricultural one
dominates and informs the social peace
this as a community this is a place to
go this is a reason to get up in the
morning this has a choice between
something that's going to bring you down
and something that might
be positive and you know
this is where you're getting hung up
right here
but these guys they don't give up on you
you don't show up you're not feeling too
good you're not making it come back the
next day we'll keep working you don't
get fired here
and hey you're not coming every day oh I
missed one day uh last month and that's
the only day I missed
I do all the seating here just about
yeah I guess I'm the boss for here
to tell people where they need to be
what needs to get done and stuff like
that but it's only my second year and
I'm still learning and I'm learning from
the best Melissa is a beast she might be
small she's strong too she can work her
butt off
she's awesome she's um he really kind of
holds us all together for us and
and she's a good weeder thanks at least
I know I can't mess that up
why do I do this some days I don't know
I mean y'all want the world to be a
better place and I think that there's
real for me personally there was a lot
of transformative power in in
agriculture in my life
I come from a really privileged world I
I went to University which was paid for
primarily by my parents I grew up in a
stable household with a really loving
family
I had people all along telling me that I
could do things
it is quite hard coming in this you try
to find a common ground with people
yeah I don't know what it's like to go
through opiate withdrawal I don't know
what it's like to be not be able to get
my prescription in the morning when I
need it every day
[Music]
there's days when like I really can't
understand what someone's dealing with
but you can be compassionate
[Music]
a lot of people on the east side are
great people it's just that they don't
think that they're worth
the puddle that they're stepping in
and that's the truth right
[Music]
I've been a heroin addict for about 20
years
I battle with addiction and uh
it didn't matter to them
right like it didn't matter to them
like you know I had track marks it
didn't matter
it I wasn't being judged you know like
what's going on here right
the power of what we've done here has to
be shared both by the influence of the
soil and the plants and the healthy food
but also by the community of people who
have been involved with this experience
it's about the people
[Music]
what we see emerging is what we call a
regenerative economy in in very simple
terms we're having this conversation
because our bodies have been our and are
continuing to regenerate so we're
sustainable because we're regenerating
and uh and the whole universe works that
way and we see it everywhere usually
driven by the intuition of an
entrepreneur who has no theoretical
framework in mind they Intuit it so
that's why I'm confident that it's an
emergent property and it's amazing how
how often we see these patterns
repeating themselves
foreign
[Music]
Cooperative is located in London's old
East Village
tight Community Vibrant Community a
community that's really has its own
identity and is kind of moving forward
[Music]
I suppose it's got its roots in uh my
friend Marcus receiving a used book for
his birthday papasians
new complete Joy of home brewing and he
sent me an email and said hey you want a
brew beer and I liked beer I had no idea
it could be made
we were Brewing together you know in my
garage just with you know something we
built it was a propane fired gravity fed
system I mean we didn't paint it up even
to look nice it was very utilitarian it
made beer it made very good beer
everybody has a good time brewing the
beer everybody has a good time sitting
around and chatting and usually beer
brings out some good debate brings out
brings people together
it was a very makeshift system uh that
we had you know thrown together and
garage door wide open so the propane
fumes could go out and you know you're
just having a lot of fun brewing beer
and uh we started to realize these
recipes are actually people kind of like
them and it's starting to work and we
looked at different models of of
Cooperative Brewing ways that a brewery
could both be
financially viable would also be
collectively owned and we couldn't
figure it out so we just kept Brewing
but we just enlarged The Circle at that
point it was myself Dave Dave often
jokes that he got involved because he
had a grudge
um it's partially true foreign
I think people want to be in on big
decisions that matter
how to structure that becomes really
tricky we have to learn that it doesn't
come naturally
The Cooperative is simply a one-person
one-vote ownership structure so you you
get a group of people together everybody
gets a vote and you set up a company or
a bank or a store or a farm it's a very
simple structure
um
we purposely located ourselves in Old
East Village it's a neighborhood we love
it's a neighborhood that many of us live
in and so we want to be part of that
community so we don't want to have a
huge you know pollutions viewing kind of
operation we want to have a community
Brewery so one that everybody feels they
can be a part of everyone feels that is
doing things that are in the best
interest of the community
co-ops I mean they're a very old
business model they're an underutilized
business model and I mean at their
premise they're Baltimore equitable
distribution of power and wealth if we
just make a couple of notes of positive
and then things to improve on maybe the
the idea is a very
beautiful one when you think about how
it can work and how everyone works
together do it on a night that
like on a Friday or Saturday night
potentially when we're going to be busy
in the cellar it's one number one book
it's not one dollar one vote so it
doesn't matter how much of the company
you own how much you have invested
um it's that you have a stake in the
outcome
that's a food that's a real food though
so there's no need for a president
there's no need for a secretary but they
say no no you need to have one what kind
of Corporation doesn't have a president
so it's about engagement
it's about folks having control over the
workplace as much as they also end up in
a position of the workplace having a
control over them right
beautiful and
a lot of my co-workers view this job and
if you're coming into this job from a
non-cooperative structure I think it can
be very different but I do think it it
encourages folks to view their work
differently and therefore work in in a
different way
we're not taught to cooperate and we're
not taught to trust
um think of all the board games that we
play when we're kids I just remember
playing with my cousins in the Monopoly
it's about being at the top working
together working together is really hard
um and when everyone has I mean the
purpose of a worker Co-op is democracy
between workers
um so when everyone has an equal voice
it it can be difficult to reach a
consensus but yeah basically human
interaction is hard especially when
there's not a hierarchy saying you know
I'm the manager this is what we're gonna
do
we can all work together for somebody
else's goals so cooperation to me means
deciding on those goals together
and maybe it's the benefit of having a
brewery is that you get together and you
have kind of that you know habermasian
Cafe style where everybody debates it's
that that's the democracy
and not a voice that's just understood
through a vote but a true voice at the
table
while we're having a baby in a few
months yeah really soon coming up really
fast you know this has brought another
aspect of long-term planning into our
Co-op meetings and the development of
our Co-op so you know what does what
does maternity leave look like well we
have to decide that right what does
paternity leave look like
is it going to be possible for me to
step away from my daily job for you know
three four months maybe longer
um which brings us to another
complication which is where do we find
more people with the you know the vision
that we have the dedication we have to
our work
[Music]
who was I speaking to the other day who
said never get in business with your
friends and it's just like I don't know
who I'd want to work with otherwise
because if they don't know you if they
don't know your story then how do they
understand where you're coming from
100 with one is what I've been doing
yeah but I've had a couple boys
it can be a real difficulty to be
cooperative at all times right to work
in a democratic way and to make sure
that everyone's on board
again
the real reality in the corporate world
you have a child and you need to take
time off you're falling behind
[Music]
might be easier to do if it were just a
straight up business sometimes if you
didn't have to deal with relationships
and you have to deal with cooperation
you might be able to do something that
was far more efficient than what we have
but it wouldn't we wouldn't be the ones
doing it it'd be somebody else
[Music]
I would kind of come to I guess like the
end of my rope with job hunting and had
applied for several things and wasn't
really getting anywhere and saw this job
posting and I was like oh well somebody
who knows how to work with food and can
talk to chefs I'm like well that's
pretty much what I've been doing my
whole life so that job has got my name
written all over it
I guess technically I'm a salesperson
but maybe this is why I'm good at sales
is because I don't like sales I just let
the quality of what we do speak for
itself and they either want it or they
don't want it I don't want to sell
something to someone who doesn't want it
there's like there's it's dishonest
my job is what I call Quality Control so
I mean everything you see here I I make
sure that I I go through everything
before it comes here so
that means everything's as best as
possible and as perfect as possible
it's one of the things that Soul food's
always been about it's not it's always
been about quality we will not put
anything out though you know we wouldn't
take ourselves or more likely better
than we get better than we would eat
ourselves
another bonus I get that some people
don't get I get to work the markets
so I see the finished product and then I
see the people that are buying that
product for a really good price and how
happy they are with it
people are happy with our product and I
love that
that's why it's important that they're
nearby that's why another thing why we
choose them is they they get it you know
they understand the difficulties that we
have we're very very small first of all
and every day the menu is different it's
what's ever in season whatever is fresh
whatever they're proud of they send to
us and then we use that as inspiration
thank you
it's embodied in how you feel when
you've done this work how you feel when
you see somebody who's eating the food
and comes back and tells you how
incredible it is those are the things
that are so intangible and so difficult
to put a value on
one yeah
oh that's gonna be good
these overpasses
they're going to come down in four years
and when they do where we sit right now
where there's these wonderful crops
growing you know carrots and the
Radicchio and the arugula and parsleys
and whatever is here will be replaced
with high rises and people will be
living on this land where we sit right
now
20 or 30 stories up
as far from this
[Music]
as you can possibly get
[Music]
so what we're doing today is going up
and down the corridor in the old East
Village which is where we wish to
maintain our presence as a brewery
looking at potential spaces
step okay right now we're in a lease
situation so if we could potentially
purchase a building if that makes more
sense either sharing it with other
businesses Etc that's what we're
interested in doing so we're kind of
doing walkthroughs
at some point at some point here not
that long ago
at least it's easy to find where the
roof is leaking
it's a lot of opportunities a lot of
options and we're trying to just
determine what what options are in fact
opportunities and what may be uh money
pits if you were
the second level's been renovated I put
75 000 in there brand new I mean that it
would be this the skateboard Co-op main
floor right skateboard co-op on the main
floor yeah yeah what is the next one
down 658 yeah yeah that's cool because
uh we like the skateboard Club we're
good guys yeah we don't mess around with
our spot oh no they're cool I already
got a spot for them they actually might
go there uh regardless if you buy it or
not yeah yeah because they they wanna
they wanna go over there we've already
talked to us about it yeah I talked
about it a couple weeks ago oh this is
that that building yeah yeah yeah if you
want it they're taken care of trust me I
love those guys
yeah that's awesome and we support that
100 so maybe we'll stop looking right
now this place is we want to stay here
yeah yes that if it doesn't work out for
us here that we'll try to get the father
and son's building but this is 100 like
where you want to be yeah oh dude yeah
now we're just on a tour
yeah that's what we were just told that
out back we're like what now we didn't
we didn't know that wow yeah but a
certain level of honesty
[Applause]
I started talking about this landlord
nonsense yeah the owners of these
buildings come on
yeah
we did a bunch of stuff and we're
planning on making a ramp tonight like
Jim's like what are you guys doing here
no we want this building yeah so like oh
come on these guys are friends that's no
good yeah so we gotta clean that up
foreign
you need small businesses that may not
have a ton of capital in order to buy it
to at least have a reasonable
expectation that the building won't be
swept out from under them as soon as it
becomes profitable with somebody else
[Music]
this neighborhood provides a real
opportunity in that it can become if we
want it to be it can become a place
where all are accepted where we have a
mixed neighborhood where people from all
income brackets all walks all
backgrounds have a capacity to interact
and and build a good life that's what
we're aiming for
there are some pretty big
um
obstacles in our way and
quite directly it's those who control
the property are in our way
it's not money I mean money is it's a
necessity in this world but that's truly
not the relationships we're trying to
build
collaboration is ultimately the more
sustainable approach than than
competition whereas of course our
competitive capitalist system in Wall
Street no more than anywhere is rooted
in the idea that you know this false
understanding of Darwin what Darwin said
is the fittest in fact he didn't even
coin the term survival of the fittest
but the way he used it is fittest as in
the one that fits best within the whole
system not the strongest
[Music]
hello my name is Timbers Preston Channel
people know me at Stevie
is first came to Canada I was 14 years
old
and I went to University at Marielle for
masters in applied physics
laser applications to biology and
Medicine
I work here at the sensory collab
santorica is this new type of
organization where you're free to join
and to take initiative and start new
projects it is a commercial venture and
you work collaboratively with people and
you share the revenue according to
everyone's contribution it is a
decentralized network and there is no
boss
we focus on material production meaning
Hardware
Electronics we put stuff together
so we're trying to solve how material
staff could be produced in an open way
since hurricane started by focusing on
Open Source Hardware but on the high-end
side so we said let's first prove that
open source can produce scientific
instruments five years ago Open Source
Hardware was just starting now we see
drones and 3D printers these these two
industries are driven by open source
this is the main Hub of the network
where things happen where Hardware gets
done prototyped and produced and there's
other people working from their own
little home labs around the world that
do some prototyping and then we mirrored
here we're democratizing here access to
the Micron World traditionally these
these pieces can cost you tens of
thousands of dollars open source
maybe 20 of the cost allow scientific
labs in universities in the emerging
world to do their science
my background is in lasers so everything
you see with Optics the optical fiber
that's that's my contribution to the
projects yes I mean the mechanical side
and the electronics part uh these are
other people that have contributed to it
it's a collaborative work I think
there's many uh different sections here
so this is our micro 3D printer which
will be used for
microfluidic chips design what we do we
add an optical fiber it's just the size
of a little hair so this is like a pan
of light that solidifies or polymerizes
the the resin that you put inside and
you're able to do tiny tiny tiny
structures it just needs a bit of
integration but the proof of concept is
is done so that's something that will go
on crowdfunding pretty soon the tiniest
printer in the world foreign
people here are motivated by what's the
next big thing we can work on here uh
that can can be so disruptive right from
microfility devices and democratizing
testing of food and water quality how to
automate a garden how to automate a
greenhouse well here's all the
electronics that you need in the
software to run it we affectionately
call this the iPod
a completely autonomous flower pot we
have a atmospheric temperature and
humidity sensor so the plant knows if
the air is dry or if the air is very
humid and it knows the temperature
and here we have a light sensor so the
plant knows when to turn the LED off on
based on how much light it got during
the day
you know to scientific instruments that
reduce the cost of innovation allows
people in Africa and Asia and South
America to to catch up with scientific
development
so I think we're highly motivated by by
these kind of projects the real change
happens when economic relationships
change and and so then the idea was
let's set up new economic organizations
based on these new principles
by respecting some fundamental
principles that were behind what was
already existing so let's build the
Enterprise of the future and that was
the seed value for the centurica network
first you have to release all the air
you have okay so you can jump into the
water and then you can try to catch the
Stars by exhaling okay breathing is a
project we started for children with
cystic fibrosis
hit the banana
oh you hit him it's really about making
therapy fun
I mean the therapy is quite a challenge
for uh chronic illnesses and about one
person over two doesn't do the therapy
well
it's another site I have to do daily
so it's quite tedious and yeah boring
okay yeah so the games make the therapy
fun but it also gives the feedback to
them about your breathing to
too low or too high or yeah
we just connect the this medical device
to the computer so that we can use the
the data for the game and for the
research too if you want to print sensor
value for hospitals it's costing at
least a thousand five hundred dollars
so it's not something you can have at
home easily if we include all the parts
that we plan to add such as the memory
card and the battery and so it would be
about 200 dollars in a later phase we
want to do a microchip and it would
reduce the cost to maybe sixty eighty
dollars the costs of innovation using
open source is very low these products
can be 10 of the market price
so you're sinking the cost of innovation
and you're taking away some costs of
production or assembly
here's the file printed at your local
3D printing shop and then put it
together IKEA style
it really reduces the cost of a product
with like open licenses someone could
take this and improve it
and Richard re-share it but once it's
completed the how-to is going to be put
out to the world and everyone that has
the capacity to replicate the the device
can do it
no cost but there's also going to be
potentially a commercial aspect to it
how's that going to work yeah the
question is Open Source Hardware
a viable uh you know business model you
have something at home to bake something
to bake bread oh yes I do everybody has
right why don't you make your own bread
you find tons of recipes on the internet
why don't you make it
you know and then you make money on
convenience you say I can Source the
parts for you put them in a bag and send
them to you open source how their
businesses also survive on Services okay
people are asking yeah but if you can
patent how can you protect people are
going to copy you you might gather your
team to protect your idea and develop it
okay but then you patent it and you
protect it
what if tomorrow somebody uh thinks of
something that you guys didn't think of
and improves it and all of the sudden uh
releases they're they're taking new
technology it is better than yours so
yours is obsolete so you're you're
patent
uh is useless
this is a journey we're on a journey to
figure this out I'm pretty confident
that the regenerative frame is the right
frame and a regenerative frame means
that a system is is self-organizing
self-refueling
self-learning and and so you know we see
it in lots of projects in the world it
is it is emergent
did we mention not to to by Ray here or
are we vibrating
an over bottle okay yeah okay let's try
that we want to try that yeah that's
right let's try it at the top
foreign
a good listener is somebody who can
understand meaning
beyond what people actually say
very few of us actually can find right
away particularly the words that we want
to use to explain what we mean
and a good listening skill
is the ability to sense
what's behind what people obviously
say
if you're playing a faster Tempo then we
can't fit together and I think you'll
see between us let's real hard for him
too yeah well let's try it again see if
we can kind of
feel this a little bit more together
[Music]
oh
yeah
foreign
if you're describing Lumia to your
brother I think you would say something
like
um lumio is a you know simple technology
that enables people to come together to
talk an issue through generate ideas and
come to a queer shared understanding
together and a decision about what
action to take together
the idea came out of our experience
during the Occupy Movement of the the
potential for collaborative decision
making when the process is well held it
can be totally amazing like
transformative for people when diverse
perspectives can genuinely feed into a
collaborative process you know groups
can end up making more Intelligent
Decisions than any individual would by
themselves
at the red Victorian we invite many
people to be part of the decision-making
process and the way that we do that is
we provide them a link to lumio
I'd love to get people to chime in the
next day or two well yeah in the next 24
hours on the Lumia thread and then at
least I'll have some kind of direction
to start a conversation with them
things are decided fully on lumos some
things involve the offline component as
well for larger issues we tend to then
take that Lumia conversation meet in
person and kind of go over some of the
nuances
um as a group and so it's like do we
want to like take that battle on as our
owner so when a discussion gets to the
point where someone in the group thinks
hey we can make a decision here I've got
an idea this is what I think the group
should do they can put up a proposal and
so you've got discussion on the lift of
the screen and decision making on the
right and a proposal always has a time
limit on it so it always comes to a
clear conclusion so you've got this sort
of Divergence and the discussion and
then you converge on a shared outcome
and agreed outcome people participate in
a decision by clicking one of four
buttons so you can either agree or you
can sort of opt out or abstain or you
can disagree which is like saying I
don't know that it's the best idea yeah
but I'm not going to stand in the way of
the group or you can block or raise a
red flag which is saying like I think
this is a really bad idea I've got a
serious concern that I would like to be
addressed before we move forward with
this
I think that Lumia is really interesting
for the fact that it creates space for
people to kind of take the time to deal
with their emotions and then process
them often in more constructive Ways by
writing writing down what they're
thinking there's all kinds of like you
know awful stuff that happens online
bullying but lumios sort of designed
with that
um I guess with this idea in mind that
if we design online environments in a
way that makes certain types of behavior
easier uh you know so really Fosters a
sense of respectful constructive
dialogue I mean it's really about people
coming together to achieve a shared
purpose in a way that works for all of
the people involved and it's kind of
that simple like little kids get the
stuff you know we have 12 year old kids
using lumio effectively in their schools
with parents and teachers making
decisions together
I think that lumio really catalyzes
those kinds of conversations because you
pick up on those nuances and you start
to see them and it's not just actually
the technology it's the types of
collaborative structures that technology
enables
this idea that we expect democracy from
our government and we totally find with
like tyranny or dictatorship in our
workplaces for some reason even though
that's where we spend eight hours a day
for most of our lives so I have a lot of
hope that that's changing it feels like
there's a real movement building around
changing
it's just people coming together to
achieve something around the creation of
value and the Cooperative structures
we've found it to be totally flexible
enough to to have a real room to move to
be adaptive to be set things up in a
resilient way that does invoke
specialization and your most effectively
serves the social mission
foreign
car we found a system which is the value
accounting system where we can log our
time and as soon as we have finances we
can use the log we created to
redistribute the money pizza number one
century is a network where people come
collaborate on different projects and
the idea is that the system that we have
put in place captures all these
contributions from different individuals
in the context of that particular
project and then we decide how to share
the benefits according to
the value equation according to a value
equation which which is a social
contract that we make and we agree on
before the project starts so there's
five percent that goes actually to
sustain the infrastructure to sustain
the labs okay so let's take this little
part here and nobody eats this one right
and now here's a guy that contributed
let's say
a quarter
our system allows anybody in the world
to contribute as much or as little as
they want so somebody's going to get
just a little piece and that's fine
because this guy is probably doing
something else he's working on other
projects and that's his little
contribution here I'm gonna take this
piece I'm going to be honest
how I got to the participatory economy
is by having been shocked you know with
my previous job
in 2006 I left Montreal to the Silicon
Valley in San Francisco and this is
where I got my first job as an engineer
in a company manufacturing lasers
I was very stimulated I put a lot of
heart into into the work
and then 2008 financial crisis comes and
then you see how people are treated once
they're not
an acid anymore so I just got laid off
and kicked out essentially that led me
to use the internet to find Solutions
and I realized how much power the
internet can give to an individual and
to groups so that frustration turned
into something constructive
[Music]
like first came
not much
and I didn't speak French Canada was was
pretty open to immigration from Romania
back then I think the second community
that adopted us was the Italian
Community we spoke Italian and they were
more established than Romanians who were
just arriving so you started here
for sure I didn't speak French
and then slowly slowly I started to pick
up orders Tony was here every week those
were the days my friend beautiful days
now all of a sudden you got smart
whatever you do I hope it makes a change
what do you think about change
if it comes from you it's probably a
good thing
yeah
in Romania is the capital of watermelon
this is something that we eat every day
do you need help
yes yes go ahead and it drives my mother
crazy the way we live yeah
I knew the truth since I was young
because my father was very open about it
my father was in prison in Romania when
he was young he always stood up against
the regime so I grew up in an
environment where you know idealism
comes first
they're very very supportive parents you
know are we speaking about what people
have done for society so it runs deep
safe
they just dropped everything to flee the
country and that was to give us a better
future
thank
you
foreign
people actually come to this kind of
notion of
what I call building the next Society
building the next system or
they come to it from different reasons
some come out of a lot of pain and
poverty and excruciating difficulties
either try something new or we're in
real trouble
another part of it I think is
kind of it's cultural but it's also
people who who really crave getting away
from individualism
somehow but the hunger for what
community can bring
[Music]
sometimes we can just play through the
music the first time's not so good but
then even without words it it evolves
into something I mean we're just all
giving and taking at the same time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Park we wanted to make this place a
better place for everyone
I'm originally from India and one of my
husband's friend he gave a tour of
Thorncliffe Park and the first day
itself we felt home here
the next day when we got up and we
wanted to walk in the neighborhood we
walked into the park and we were really
not happy with the condition of the park
and all but when we are here we have to
fix things
we came to know about a lot of women who
live in this apartment buildings mostly
the Immigrant and they are doing
businesses from home
they bring stuff from their home
countries and then sell it to their
neighbors friends at a very good price
and make a supplement income for
themselves
when we come together we talk about oh
this is our like backyard because always
we in back home we are when we are
leaving house always have backyard or
friend yeah they are in the building you
don't have any backyard on your private
so we call this there is a backyard so
in backyard we have to have some
activity too
so we thought that this is a really uh
good idea to create a market this Market
will serve as a platform for the vendors
and these newcomer women where they will
feel confidence and you know and it will
also Empower them build their self
self-esteem and build that clientele as
well
the magic is
what you think it will be inside
you will afraid
foreign
the park completely transformed people
gathered they started looking from their
apartment buildings and we could see the
change in the park
I'm making a Roti Roti in Persian we say
this is naan and the dough for Roti is
different because we add yeast for this
one
in Parks serve as a common space for
them where they meet immigrants and new
Canadians spend some good time having
tea coffee
that was the main goal
we are waiting waiting until Friday come
when we fly they come we come out just
we enjoy there is something just because
of Market we come out
[Music]
as the new immigrants a lot of events go
through stress and isolation on a
regular basis so I and we thought like
this Market would serve as a stressor
living agent or something like that
where people feel really good when they
come Outdoors
I mean it's good to empower empowerment
movements they support their house their
children yeah so yeah that's the main
course yeah to empowerment of women
ladies
so yeah did you buy any tray for
yourself did you buy any canopy for
yourself next year
so you won't be coming to the market
there are challenges and there are
achievements right we started with zero
nothing in our hands and but we had a
strong Vision we had that commitment to
give it to the community to return back
to the community
the community comes up with their own
ideas and out because they can feel
comfortable they feel they see us as
their the part of their own self which
is really uh challenging for us to take
everyone's uh suggestion to work on one
thing but we do accept the suggestions
and we choose how best those things fit
into what we are really trying to do I
mean looking at the bigger goal
foreign
passed away recently and for her these
are the opportunities which provide
supplement income for her to run her
house and she has kids and she has to
look after them and the moreover is when
she comes to the market she comes with
the friends and they are supportive and
you know they are always there for her
it's like a building family kind of
environment in the market and they're
all friends come to the market to eat
what she is making and they love doing
it thank you enjoy
[Music]
you know when I look at their faces I
can see in their eyes you know that I
can sense that the happiness and that is
I think that's the value this Market is
bringing it's emotionally and though
there is definitely a financial support
for them but still it is like more about
building relationship building trust
she's very nice and she always support
us and this she's doing
thank you so much my pleasure thank you
so much
maybe there is no reward
cooperation works well maybe you're just
in the process and the process is the
reward
there's something that's innately
satisfying about that
sorry sorry can we do it again we didn't
start together I don't know why but we
weren't able to work together music
itself would suffer and it would be
probably we wouldn't be able to
communicate effectively as a group the
music might still sound like music but
it just wouldn't be convincing we
wouldn't have the organic quality that
we are always striving for
[Music]
should we just do it one more time with
the song Young now see and then I'll
join in the end because I'm it's my
part's easy yeah let's see how it works
here's our motor right we have this
engine then we have the car driver
process in the process itself is
very satisfying you know you go through
stages and you come to a different
result but all the stages you know it's
enjoyable yeah I would just say it's a
lot more fun there's certain times when
you have to play like a soloist when the
virtuosic passage in every one of our
parts and there's no leader but then
we're all leaders too so it's just it's
just it's just a great experience
foreign
[Music]
but it definitely wasn't a good guy you
know you know you got to leave that [ __ ]
behind you if you want to grow right
and so that's what I've been trying to
do
the farms in themselves by nature of the
what we're doing here are kind of like
the great equalizer you know like if
you're out there picking radishes or
filling boxes or planting trees or it
doesn't matter what your history is how
much suffering you've been through it
really levels you off
yeah it was a good opportunity to get to
into the uh giving back Department a bit
right you know working for your
community a bit right instead of taking
from it all the time it wasn't a big
idea that we were going to go out and
you know
rescue people you know we just our idea
was set the table here
and do it with
soil and seeds and growing food and
allow that process to do what it does to
for all of us you know I you know people
ask me why I farm I you know
I it's as much for my mental health as
it is for anybody else who's working
here I'm in this I'm in no different I'm
we're different in some ways but we're
all alike in other ways for me too right
like you put something in a seed in the
ground
you nurture it you care for it and it
gives you something back
yeah it is something actually that
changes
changes you
we've survived a lot of crazy stuff but
I think it's important enough to the
people who we work with that it has to
continue
and it's important enough that it has to
include more people who haven't been
able to take part
um and our goal is not unlike most
social service agencies is not to
graduate people and send them down the
road
you know we feel like we want them to be
for as long as they want to be able to
come here yeah
first time I met this guy and I was like
who is this guy you know yeah and you
had kind of a hard Edge well I wasn't
very like socially integrated either
right well you were new yeah it was
this guy's got the softest core you hear
that guy he's got a really scared me on
tape he has a good heart he's got a good
heart I might need that one day his
characteristics
no I mean it's blows my mind yeah but
you know what you've gone through the
kind of [ __ ] that you've gone through
and that you're yeah I appreciate you
stand up I do you guys don't have the
Monopoly on suffering by the way oh yes
I know this and so I'm just saying for
me
you know I needed to do this
for myself as much as for anybody else
and that's the honest truth
it's hard to admit but it's true I mean
I got my own stuff I got to deal with
actually the you know music is sort of
like a reflection of life but this
medium allows to have a conversation
with a different uh people at different
times and and if it's works well it's
it's it's it's it's really it's really
good
[Music]
it's very clear to me that to have a
healthy system Finance is a is a piece
of a bigger whole and needs to be in
service of that hole
the basic premise of investment is to
invest money in order to create more
money at the end we call that return on
Capital but it's it's money in creating
more money out
so we've grown a pile of money while
we've destroyed the atmosphere that
that's not sustainable there's a whole
sense of that that we've got to go
beyond just profit making which takes no
regard for what happens to the
environment
and another piece of it is is human and
communitarian trying to build a
different sense of community
but those themes I think democracy
wealth changing wealth ownership
environment Community participation
those are the themes that we're seeing
develop in many parts of the country in
many parts of the world
I I think of the first time the beer was
served at The Root Cellar I mean that
feeling is is tremendous and and you
realize that hey people are enjoying
this it's not just us there's a great
mix of younger folks older folks women
men those who are coming in who who
might not feel that the beer culture is
currently really speaking to them that
might feel alienated I think our
approach helps to kind of even that
playing field where it's like yeah this
is a you know it's a good beverage I
love craft beer I just do and really in
London there's not a lot of options
right now and as soon as I found I'm
like I'm just happy that I have a beer
that I enjoy and the whole Co-op ideas
is so cool I've actually never
experienced that in a beerwise the big
Brewers out there who are their their
sales in volume and that's that's their
Market the more they can sell the better
there's a lot of beers you drink one and
it tastes the same as the other and
these ones every like when you look down
even the colors are different the
flavors are different it's worth
supporting yeah when they named some of
their beers you recognize the name of it
was the spring it Stout these are farms
that I grew up around the corner from
they're bringing in local ingredients
and making a fantastic beer with it
there's some morality to their business
like these guys aren't going to make it
rich that's not the point of their
business they're providing good beer for
the community making jobs in the
community it's a fantastic way to to
kind of go about it
we've known for decades that if you
circulate money and materials in a local
economy you get these multiplier effects
and so by circulating money and
materials and information in a local
economy you're going to be more in
alignment with the regenerative process
that actually
run you know is that the way the world
works
what I really love about that kind of
community engagement is our neighborhood
tart so it was a wheat base with rhubarb
and that rhubarb came from old East
Village so we had somebody take up the
cause she went around and just Chats on
the street trying to find rhubarb in
people's backyards we've got a ton of it
we threw it into the Brew it was really
tasty and I think for us it again just
it's a lot of fun I mean beer can be a
lot of fun
right now we brew an incredibly
inefficient beer it's it is not a
turnkey process it is not pressing a few
buttons and things work it is a it is a
labor of love but it is a lot of Labor
right now and so we're hoping to
streamline some of those processes by an
expansion so that we can focus on
the kind of value that we feel our beer
is bringing as well the the Hops for the
next one are sitting over there with the
Irish moss in the latest edition
Brewing is an economy of scale thing it
takes largely the same amount of Labor
to produce one barrel of beer as it does
to produce 10 times that amount
the London Brewing Co-op at its current
size it physically doesn't work
so we need to scale up and in order to
scale up we need more space we need well
resources time energy to do that
we're going to need some investors
willing investors to to believe in the
co-op model believe in our product and
believe in the local food movement
I don't know that Josie's ever been down
here
so I think a lot is demonstrating what
what works what what's here
we know what the expansion looks like
225 to 250. that's I mean that's not
including a purchase but if I got an
investment opportunity for you and in
the material w
we absolutely thank you for joining us
yeah thanks for having us in your
business
we've done here and maybe where we could
go into the future financing in part may
come from londoners who support our
vision and our dream and we want it to
be angel or patient investment where
they believe in the the purpose of what
we're doing not just the fiscal return
that they will receive I think certainly
those those short-term goals that you
know the expansion of the the brewery
system that would be in a lease
situation so it's specific investors
that we're looking for who understand
our vision and believe in it and that
will include doing the renovations in
the next building moving the brewery
there and having it up and going okay
yeah we'll get that to you sir yeah
absolutely and if you have any questions
you know anything putting into it just
let me know yeah absolutely fantastic
yeah it drives me nuts when I start
talking this way and people oh you're a
socialist or you're a communist it has
nothing to do with it this has nothing
to do with socialism versus capitalism
this is how real systems in the real
world work and and that's physics and
biology and energy everything is energy
this is the way it works from a tornado
to boiling water in a pot to
um insects to entire ecosystems to human
bodies to human consciousness to the
entire universe itself is a learning
living system
[Music]
foreign
we are in Whistler BC at the impact
economy Summit we've been trying to cook
a new economic model for the cities and
media ecosystem there's a lot of energy
in the room with ups and downs which is
normal for this kind of interactions
discussions and working together
so this is Building Bridges right
Building Bridges between the open world
and the classical world so that we can
establish these flows of resources in
this process of metamorphosis right we
can't just start building from scratch
from nothing we are within the system
and by establishing these interfaces and
the trust okay we can allow these
resources to flow this is not in any way
a classical business right this is not
this is not around the cooperation that
wants to maximize profit for its
shareholders I see traditional
corporations as boxes okay so there are
spaces of confinement
that limits you in what you want to do
let's say you have a project and you go
to a corporation and the question is do
we have the budget or the budget that
number is a parameter that confines you
do we have the skills
so essentially looking in a box and you
see what's in there how much money we
have how much people we have so NASA is
doing a lot of prizes and this is
competitive crowdsourcing you have a
price you have a project and you say all
right who comes up with the best design
you know they get the price and there's
a lot of redundancy and everyone spends
money for their own prototyping and and
for delivering something and then you
have one winner and the rest that loses
and the only thing they take home is is
the experience right so with the value
accounting system we say well why don't
why don't you collaborate and log your
contributions Financial materials time
everything you put in there and then the
price you share it according to
everyone's contribution okay so you turn
competitive crowdsourcing into
collaborative crowdsourcing what you're
building is a set of businesses that
feed the community because this is a
real Paradigm Shift what you're doing is
it's this is not capitalism as we know
it this is something entirely different
yes
then it's clear that this is really you
know the way to go for me this is the
kind of answer to a big problem that we
have today which is
you know you don't get paid for things
you like to do you only get paid for the
things you don't like to do so I think
the system that is actually able
you know to to create livelihoods
without destroying the planet and
without creating social Strife is the
one that eventually hopefully has to win
out because otherwise we're all doomed
anyway
everyone wants to take their seats that
would be lovely
I will go home with with a positive
message
um that you know what we're doing is
important that is is perceived as
important which is a validation of what
we do
yeah
so that's why I leave for this kind of
moments this is the currency I'm looking
for
I met some people that said UTB you can
fail because you've been there and
you've paved the way
and if sensoryca fails then it sends
this message they say holy [ __ ] so now
I'm kind of Trapped with all this
responsibility to to show that yes it
can be done
everything is converging towards a more
collaborative economy for sure and when
you free people economically they're
free
[Music]
I like that noise the tape it's like
you're moving man the actual lab space
that we have now it's it's pretty packed
there's a lot of people
so very crowded it's a kind of tough on
us to have to move but it's something
that we have to do and we're pretty
tired we're pretty uh drained
there's a new chapter for centaurica
we are really coming out you know we're
getting exposed downtown Montreal
I see myself as part of the Montreal new
economy setup
we're taking over guys
Belly of the Beast visibility presence
legitimacy right in people's face
when it's time for you to go you know
you look back and and you're not going
to count your money or your material
positions I think the things that will
give you more satisfaction is do I leave
a Trace
[Music]
well the greatest hope for the
collaborative economy is to have this
smooth transition without too many bumps
because we can feel that we're
frustrating
uh the losers and they're powerful
[Music]
there's no lamb I'm hoping that we're
gonna get some acreage in the middle of
a park that has to be developed here
we need a permanent location
we need multiple locations but we need
one permanent location to replace
specific when the viaducts come down
we need more people who can really carry
the workload
and I think eventually we could if
people felt that incentive
that they had something at stake beyond
their hourly wage
developed something that was did return
something to our staff but we're not
there yet
I want them to come to work because
they're working for themselves and
they're working for their own healing
and for a community of farmers and
eaters that surround it you know
I want them to feel that sense of
ownership
[Music]
I think that's probably better than
stock options or
shared ownership or anything I mean
we've had this idea of a Cooperative
turning this into workers own
cooperative
but the truth is what would they be on
there's nothing to own so what we can
offer is is is this shared experience of
what happens in the process of doing
this work
that
oh awesome
I want to retire here I'm 56 I'll be 57
November this is this is it for me I
think it's my last stop if we last that
long this is my last stop I'm hoping we
do
all we need is boxes we can fill the
boxes we will put out whatever we need
the boxes we need infrastructure if we
get the infrastructure we will we can do
we will fill them up and we'll the
produce we're good we really are good
here's what the garden kind of taught me
like not going to help yourself it's
pretty hard for other people to help you
right it's they can't
like you know what I mean like if you're
not willing to do it
why should they invest all the time in
[ __ ] spinning their wheels
I don't know if I didn't have this job
like where would I be in the last three
years like think about it right like
dead
in an alley shooting up on a
Penitentiary those are those are my
three options so yeah
soul food saved my life right what else
can I say it did
[Music]
for me at this stage of my life
this is value to me spending time here
with my friends
feeling good about myself right I'm able
to close my eyes that night saying you
know I didn't hurt anybody today right I
did maybe a couple good things
that's value to me
foreign
so what is real wealth well let me tell
you what it's not it's not money
um
but you know there are people going
around saying we need a new theory of
value so we don't really know what that
is I can I can rattle off a few ideas so
obviously
fresh air to breathe
clean water to drink access to clean
food
family friendships community art beauty
is is obviously what we know is real
wealth
I think that's a big thing too with the
Cooperative is that the Cooperative
shifts with the needs of its workers not
just with the needs of the end products
[Music]
I think the five of us I would imagine
soon won't be the five of us from a you
know worker owner perspective I think
really we want to see that full
realization of the Cooperative so that
we can bring in new workers who have the
same values that we do so that when
people come into work it's it's because
they want to be there it's because they
know they're part of you know kind of a
larger movement and it's not
to the detriment of who they are
of course the timing is
hilarious
because I don't know is it legal to have
babies brew beer for a side effects no
but babies with like craft beer
marketing is really cute
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's like
we'll never make really good progress
until we realize that it's not a chore
to get there you know you don't have to
have a really unenjoyable life in
service to this cause it's got to be fun
right I mean like fundamentally it
actually needs to be enjoyable just
taking that approach to thinking about
how we do activism how we do social
change how we organize our work I think
it's one of the most powerful levers of
social change
I don't think we're gonna wake up one
day and say we're now in a regenerative
economy you know how did we know we were
in the enlightenment
this is a lifetime transition
and the challenge is are we going to
screw this up before we make the
transition
the symptoms that we feel will will
lighten it will feel different it will
feel healthy and then we'll say wow it
feels better
it's a very moving period of History
potentially big things can happen I
think we're at a moment maybe
always a maybe that we are laying the
groundwork for potentially not only
transformation but irreversible
transformation that's a big deal in
history it's very just intense
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]